Fox News Alert an explosive college
admissions scandal has landed two
Hollywood actresses in big trouble with
the law
Felicity Huffman and Lori Lolan are
among dozens of people charged in a 25
million dollar bribery scheme
authorities say rich parents bribed
cheated and defrauded in order to get
their kids into some of the country's
most elite schools the alleged crimes
include paying for someone to take their
kids SATs paying at admissions
consultants to bribe coaches into
labeling their kids as recruited
athletes to boost their chances and also
faking athletic profiles to make
students look like strong athletes when
they actually weren't there is no
evidence that school admissions were
involved in any of the wrongdoing the US
attorney in charge describing the
bombshell allegations the parents
charged today despite already being able
to give their children every legitimate
advantage in the college admissions game
instead chose to corrupt and illegally
manipulate the system for their benefit
we're not talking about donating a
building so that a school is more likely
to take your son or daughter we're
talking about deception and fraud fake
test scores fake athletic credentials
fake photographs bribed college
officials Felicity Huffman is expected
in court this hour while Lori Loughlin
is reportedly on a flight back to LA
where she is expected to surrender to
authorities for more let's go to
jonathan hunt who is live at the
courthouse in LA with the latest
Jonathan Jessie good afternoon to you
Felicity Huffman the actress famed for
her role in Desperate Housewives of
course among 13 people due to appear
this hour in the federal court behind me
she as well as the actress Lori Lachlan
are both one or two of dozens accused of
taking part in what was a wide-ranging
scheme essentially to bribe and defraud
the college admissions system to get
their children into colleges that those
parents presumably thought they
otherwise would not be able to get into
Felicity Huffman and her husband William
H Macy accused for instance of paying 50
thousand to alter SAT test scores Lori
Loughlin and her husband who is the
designer Massimo gia newly are accused
of paying $500,000 to have their two
daughters labeled as recruits to the USC
crew team neither of those daughters
ever took part in that sport so this was
a wide-ranging scheme one essentially
run by a company that was run out of
Newport Beach California by a man called
William singer he pleaded guilty earlier
today to racketeering now we assume that
he has given the feds much of the
evidence on which all of these charges
are based so we will now have these 13
here in LA arraigned we have not seen
Felicity Huffman at this point although
she should by all logic be inside the
court house already we have seen her
husband William H Macy he was asked if
he wanted a comment on the case his
answer was no Jesse great get there
Jonathan thank you very much all right
so Greg you were a big fan of full house
oh yes that's for house watts are you
taking this especially hard I am damaged
by the news this is the great thing
about this scandal is that when they
make the movie everyone can play
themselves because who can play felicity
Felicity Huffman better than Felicity
Huffman she's an amazing actress but
there's a couple of things people are
often as sinful well our sinful as their
options allow them to be so you have to
ask yourself if this option were allowed
for you to help your kid get a leg up
would you do it so it's like we can
dislike what they do but we have to
wonder what if we had that option but it
does show that a lot of people really
enjoy this story because by oh we have a
biological revulsion to line cutting and
it everybody hates all kinds of line
cutting whether it's actually cutting in
a line or immigration or college
admissions it's something that bugs us
we are programmed to be disgusted by
people who don't get there the
right way yeah but bribing the Coyotes
yes and they were cutting in line in
front of the this is by the way this is
why I only have houseplants and not kids
because I don't need to grease a
gardeners palm you know to get them to
trim my boxwoods stupid kids are a
problem I thought there were other
reasons you didn't have kids this story
obviously everybody's interested because
like Greg said there's a long cutting
but it's also the Hollywood angle right
people are fascinated wooden big right
and now they're you know they're looking
at some hard time there's also there was
a in one of the recorded conversations
at the FBI got somebody says I'm not so
much worried about the moral part of
things I'm just worried about what's
gonna happen if we get caught and I was
like well this is what's gonna happen
you're going to be embarrassed and it's
I think what really drives it is it's
the fairness issue right so you're
you're like everybody in the world a
human being is born fairness is like in
Nate in you and and then help making
money by helping rich people get their
already privileged kids even more
privileged so that they can make more
money seems like the system is rigged
like the system is working against you
and kudos to president Trump's FBI who
went ahead and got these guys and said
that we're not gonna put up with this
anymore I don't have children either but
I do know I'm plenty of friends that do
and I know that they start talking about
paying for college before the babies are
even conceived yeah they like certain
you start wondering like how am I gonna
make this happen
getting your child into college now is
like a part-time job hmm and kids don't
even have part-time jobs because it's
their job to try to get into college cuz
I have to have all the requisite things
that they can get in there and so I'm
glad that they caught them I don't know
if it's more widespread right so hold on
these guys but does this happen
elsewhere so now like Dana said whan
parents are thinking we did my son or
daughter knock it into this school
because some rich fat cat bribed some
coach to scam them in right I mean then
there's this is not a victimless crime
there are real people who suffered as a
result of lost opportunity getting into
the very best schools in the country but
to me there's a bigger story here as you
know there's a lawsuit right now that's
been put forward by conservatives using
Asians to challenge affirmative action
at
pervert and in the course of that debate
here's what we found Jessie you know
that in fact right now if you look at it
at selective schools if you have a
legacy and that's what these people you
know these people were talking about
athletics but legacies in other words if
you went to the school and then apply
for your kids that's even bigger than
athletics thirty-four percent admitted
five times higher than people whose
parents did not go to the school so if
you went to Harvard you're already rich
entitled and famous and now your kid
applies tremendous advantage especially
if the kid has good enough grades even a
bigger boot so the the most privileged
kids in America they get the biggest
boost not the black kids not the Asian
kids not lesbian Americans and the
second point to make is athletics if a
few have an athletic credential on your
resume which is what these fraudsters
were doing they were putting pictures of
the kids on the bodies of athletes and
pushing it out there but if you're an
athlete guess what you have about a 50%
boost in terms of your likelihood to get
into a school and just one last point
most of the athletes in America despite
you see the black basketball players the
black football player it's not the black
most college athletes are white like 70%
and there are things like lacrosse crew
ice hockey I could go on forget squash
nobody product race because that's my
voice no the Conservatives are using
Asians to challenge affirmative action
at Harvard is there we got into the
Asian question let's talk about the
people named in the complaint
I read the criminal complaint and you
know what it's not about advancing their
kids and making their lives better down
the road they're embarrassed by their
dumb kids and they couldn't get into a
decent school if you've read the
complaint and I don't know if we have
the sound of it
but if you go online Olivia Jade when a
Lori Loughlin Skidz
has a YouTube channel she had a career
before she ever had to go off to USC
which she got into there because of a
fight they paid they paid five hundred
thousand dollars her parents for the two
kids to get into USC to be on the crew
and I think we have some sound of Lauren
Collins daughter that we can listen to I
don't know how much of school I'm gonna
attend but I'm gonna go in and talk to
my deans and everyone and hope that I
can try and balance at all but I do want
the experience of like gamedays partying
I don't really care about school as you
guys all know here's what her mother
said in the come in the complaint or her
father copying her mother I have some
concerns and I want to fully understand
the game plan and make sure we have a
roadmap for success as it relates to our
daughter and getting her into a school
other than ASU
so he's it was that's the other thing
about all of this is that college is
really not that important folks it's a
man it is too expensive and one of the
reasons that you have tuitions that are
so high is because people are willing to
do things like this so there's no
incentive to lower it like I'm but none
of us went to a fancy school well I did
I went away which is in the indictments
of Berkeley that's kind of fancy so
geopoint
we've elevated the importance of college
we've reduced the barrier for loans
which is ballooned the size of the
administrations and so now you have all
these kids saddled with debt but even
more because it used to be okay the
virtue signal to get a job was ABA right
but now everybody can get a BA
now what co-sponsor now it's masters so
now you got to spend more money to get a
masters and now master's isn't enough
now you go to go to PhD so now what
we're doing is no one hires people with
PhDs really go one time wouldn't even
interview you unless you went to an Ivy
you couldn't even get a job interview
even if you went to a level 2 tech you
couldn't get in and I just want to add
this you know it made sense to go to
Wake Forest it was $7,500 a year when I
started school I could major in art
history and blow it off and not get a
you know not care about the education
well I think more unlike Dana I think
College is very important because guess
what no it's not this important I think
it is very important where you learn
about identity politics one
[Laughter]
credentialing especially for low-income
kids minority kids to have the college
degree makes a huge difference and
can quantify it in terms of life timing
I agree with that I agree with that but
I would make maybe my point is this
going to an elite college is way
overblown that the importance of that I
get it I don't have I don't have
anything I don't have any connections
and I'm family I have no legacy not like
a significant University I oh man I went
to University of Southern Colorado on a
speech team scholarship right there's
like sure your mom didn't put your face
on a speech team body